did you know Google Cloud's vertex AI
supports many different machine learning
Frameworks and open source projects such
as tensorflow spark xgboost and pytorch
[Music]
pytorch now part of the open source
pytorch Foundation is one of the fastest
growing Frameworks in the community
ml practitioners using pytorch tell us
that sometimes it can be challenging to
advance their ml projects past
experimentation
vertex AI is a fully managed ml platform
that provides the tools you need to
train scale and deploy pytorch models
for example you can use the pytorch Deep
learning containers
or the vertex AI workbench pytorch
kernel as a consistent environment for
experimentation and model training
and with the torch X adapter you can
orchestrate torch X components as part
of kubeflow pipelines that you can run
on vertex AI Pipelines
if you need to scale your workloads you
can use the xla Deep learning compiler
to run pytorch on cloud tpus which are
custom accelerators designed to run
large ml workloads
finally with Google's OSS contributions
to Apache beam we've made pytorch models
easy to deploy in batch or stream data
processing Pipelines
running on dataflow these pipelines will
scale to large workloads in a fully
managed environment
so let's jump in and see how to
operationalize pytorch on Google cloud
with vertex AI we'll fine-tune a hugging
face transformer for sentiment analysis
using pytorch to automate this workflow
we'll orchestrate the pipeline in a
serverless manner using vertex AI
pipelines we'll start by navigating to
workbench and the vertex AI section of
the cloud console
vertex AI workbench is the place to go
in Google Cloud if you want to work in a
notebook so if you're already using
notebooks this environment will feel
familiar
you can create a new notebook or open up
an existing notebook instance in your
project we can create a new pytorch
notebook
and use this environment for
experimentation
but when it's time to operationalize
you're probably going to need something
more than a notebook
you can use vertex AI pipelines in
combination with other vertex AI
services to orchestrate and automate
your workflows and store any Associated
metadata you can customize the hardware
profile of the compute jobs you run
including adding gpus and tpus all
without having to worry about managing
the underlying infrastructure
the code in this notebook defines a
pipeline that trains a text classifier
and then deploys the trained model to a
Vertex AI endpoint for low latency
serving this pipeline uses a combination
of pre-built and custom components
we can compile the pipeline
then submit the job using the vertex AI
python SDK and track the progress in the
UI
vertex AI pipelines automatically logs
metadata using the vertex ml metadata
service to track artifacts lineage
metrics visualizations and pipeline
executions across your workflows
so if we examine our pipeline we can see
that it ran a custom Training job on the
vertex AI training service
the model is then conditionally deployed
to an endpoint only if the evaluation
accuracy is above a certain threshold
navigating to the vertex AI model
registry which is a repository where you
can manage the life cycle of your models
we can see our pytorch model and
endpoint
once deployed we can hit our endpoint
like any other rest endpoint to get low
latency predictions on the Fly
we hope you're inspired to start using
vertex AI to elevate your ml models out
of experimentation and into production
to try this pipeline out for yourself be
sure to check out the notebook linked
below and definitely let us know what
you're building on vertex AI
[Music]